[Music]
James Joyce's Ulysses is widely
considered to be both a literary
masterpiece and one of the hardest works
of literature to read it inspires such
devotion that once a year on a day
called blooms day thousands of people
all over the world dress up like the
characters take to the streets and read
the book aloud and some even make a
pilgrimage to Dublin just to visit the
places so vividly depicted in Joyce's
opus so what is it about this famously
difficult novel that inspires so many
people there's no one simple answer to
that question but there are a few
remarkable things about the book that
keep people coming back the plot which
transpires over the course of a single
day is a story of three characters
Stephen Dedalus reprised from Joyce's
earlier novel a portrait of the artist
as a young man Leopold Bloom a half
Jewish advertising camisole for a Dublin
newspaper and blooms wife Molly who is
about to embark on an affair
Stephen is depressed because of his
mother's recent death meanwhile bloom
wanders throughout the city he goes to a
funeral his work a pub and so on
avoiding going home because Molly is
about to begin her affair where it
really starts to get interesting though
is how the story's told each chapter is
written in a different style 15 is a
play 13 is like a cheesy romance novel
12 is a story with bizarre exaggerated
interruptions 11 uses techniques like
onomatopoeia repetitions and
alliteration to imitate music and 14
reproduces the evolution of English
literary prose style from its beginnings
in anglo-saxon right up to the 20th
century that all culminates in the final
chapter which follows Molly's stream of
consciousness as it spools out in just
eight long paragraphs with almost no
punctuation
the range of styles Joyce users in
Ulysses is one of the things that makes
it so difficult but it also helps make
it enjoyable and is one of the reasons
old book is held up as one of the key
texts of literary modernism a movement
characterized by overturning traditional
modes of writing Joyce fills his
narrative gymnastic routines but some of
the most imaginative use of language
you'll find anywhere take for instance
the figure seated on a large boulder of
the foot of a Round Tower was that of a
broad shoulder deep chested strong
limbed Frank eyed redhead freely
freckled shaggy bearded wide mouths
large nosed long headed deep voiced bear
need brawny handed hair legged ruddy
face sinew armed hero here Joyce
exaggerated the description of a mangie
old man in a pub to make him seem like
an improbably gigantic hero it's true
that some sections are impenetrably
dense at first glance but it's up to the
reader to let their eyes skim over them
or break out a shovel and dig in and
once you start excavating the text
you'll find the book to be an
encyclopedic treasure trove is filled
with all manner of references and
allusions from medieval philosophy to
the symbolism of tattoos and from Dante
to Dublin slang as suggested by the
title some of these allusions revolve
around homeless Odyssey each chapter is
named after a character or episode from
the Odyssey but the literary references
are often coy debatable sarcastic or
disguised for example Homer's Odysseus
after an epic 20-year long journey
returns home to Ithaca and reunites with
his faithful wife in contrast Joyce's
Bloom wanders around Dublin for a day
and returns home to his unfaithful wife
it's a very funny book it has highbrow
intellectual humor if you have the
patience to track down Joyce's
references and more lowbrow dirty jokes
those and other sexual references were
too much for some in the US the book was
put on trial banned and censored before
it even being completed because it was
originally published as a serial novel
readers of Ulysses aren't just led
through a variety of literary styles
they're also given a rich and shockingly
accurate tour of a specific place at a
time Dublin in 1904 Joyce claimed that
if Dublin were to be destroyed
it could be recreated from the pages of
this book while such a claim is not
exactly true it does show the great care
that Joyce took in precisely
representing details both large and
small of his home city no small feat
considering he wrote the entire novel
while living outside of his native
Holland it's a testament to Joyce's
genius that Ulysses is a difficult book
some people find it impenetrable without
a full book of annotations to help them
understand what Joyce is even talking
about but there's a lot of joy to be
found in reading it more than just
unpacking illusions and solving puzzles
and if it's difficult or frustrating or
funny
that's because life is all that and more
responding to some criticism of Ulysses
and there was a lot when it was first
published Joyce said that if Ulysses
isn't worth reading then life isn't
worth living
up to the challenge you can pick up a
copy at your nearest library or
bookstore or download an audio version
for free today at audible.com slash
ted-ed
thanks for watching and see you next
blooms day